so how can we tell if two ratios are
equivalent to one another that's what
we're going to talk about in this video
so when you talk about a ratio it's like
you're comparing two quantities like uh
teachers to students or boys to girls
right or any two quantities you're
comparing to one another and you can
write it as a fraction or you can put it
with a colon in between the two or you
can even write the word to to but in
general ratios are written as fractions
like this and we're trying to see are
these ratios equal meaning are these
fractions equal to each other well one
way to do it is to reduce the fractions
to lowest terms and then you can compare
them so for example uh 12 over 18 I can
see that I can divide the numerator by
six and the denominator by six you want
to make sure you do the same thing to
the top and bottom and you can see we're
getting 12 ID 6 is 2 18 ID 6 is 3 and so
you can see yes 2/3 is equal to 2/3 so
these two ratios or these two fractions
are equal now that's one method the
other method that you can do is What's
called the cross product okay and the
cross product just like it sounds you're
going like across on the diagonal here
and you're multiplying these quantities
together so what I mean is you'd say 2 *
18 is that the same as 3 * 12 okay so 2
* 18 is 36 3 * 12 is also 36 so since
this is true that means that these two
ratios are equivalent to one another so
let's take a look at another example see
if you can do this one you can do it
either way whichever one you prefer
let's try the reducing method first so
here I can say h what can I uh divide
both the numerator and denominator by
looks like I can divide them both by
five so five goes into 15 three times 5
goes into 35 7 times okay we reduced the
left side how about this second ratio
well it looks like six goes into
here uh both numerator and denominator
18 divid 6 is 3 48 divid 6 is 8 you can
see these fractions are not equal to
each other these ratios are not
equivalent right but the other method if
you don't like that reducing method is
to go ahead and use this cross product
method so I'm going to go to the
calculator on this one but we've got 15
* 48 we're asking ourselves is that the
same as 35 * 18 so let's see 15 * 48 is
720 and we're wondering is that the same
thing as 35 * 18 which is 630 you can
see these are not the same which tells
us that these ratios are not equivalent
so the next thing that you're going to
want to learn after you learn about
ratios is how to work with proportions
and that's what I talk about in that
video right there so follow me over to
that video and we'll dive into
proportions I'll see you there